à l'heure où la chloroquine fait
souffler un vent d'espoir aux quatre
coins du globe
la seule usine française habilitée à
produire le produit pharmaceutique se
trouve en redressement judiciaire
je cite de famars lyon est enregistrée
pour produire de la nivaquine la
nivaquine c'est le produit qui est
commercialisé dans sa molécule de
principes actifs et la chloroquine
sulfate donc c'est le seul site
enregistré pour produire la nivaquine
pour le marché français
aujourd'hui les syndicats tentent de
sauver les 250 salariés de l'entreprise
menacée de fermeture
sur les 12 sites du groupe
pharmaceutique vendus par le fonds
d'investissement américain kkr
seul le site de saint-genis-laval près
de lyon n'a pas trouvé repreneur
les employés on appelle alors à l'état
pour maintenir l'activité du site
en cette période de crise il me semble
qu'il serait normal si effectivement
aucun repreneur ne se positionnent que
l'état en fait puisse reprendre la main
de manière à maintenir l'outil de
production maintenir les emplois sur le
site mais surtout alimentée en fait
j'irai le marché poids pour pouvoir
endiguer le risque sanitaire que nous
connaissons si effectivement la
nivaquine peut être utilisé dans le
cadre du traitement du commis de 19 le
maire de la commune sur laquelle est
implantée du sin a également lancé un
appel auprès des pouvoirs publics et des
investisseurs pour tenter de sauver le
site
au regard de la situation j'en appelle
aux investisseurs privés et à l'état
pour maintenir le potentiel de
production de la chloroquine dans la
tente des tests cliniques seule
entreprise produisant ce médicament
susceptible de lutter contre le coc vite
19 la communauté scientifique et
médicale sont divisés en deux camps
concernant l'efficacité de la
chloroquine à ce jour le ministère de
l'économie n'a pas retenu la possibilité
de reprise du site de saint-genis-laval